but um you know I'm on a show now you
know I got this I'm getting back into
things and it's great it's what never
heard of this show
what's the sitcom it's got splitting up
together it's an ABC show meet Jenna
Fischer Jenna Fischer Pam yeah Wow cool
who yelled at me the other day by the
way really well don't say this story I
want to because we're made we made up it
was it was warranted with Wharton and I
[ __ ] up I I apologize glad she did
this because this is everything I've
wanted to say to you for the past six
yeah set the stove this is what happened
um so there's this lady that's on our
guest stars her name is Monica Barbara
oh and she's on the new Top Gun movie
but she she plays the love interest of
Oliver in the show that I'm on right and
because of her tops done schedule we had
to shoot all her coverage weeks ago on a
weekend right and then we did all our
coverage this week so we monitor act
into like an ad
yeah 80 basically right and also in the
coverage that we have I don't say
anything
it's just reaction of her talking or her
singing a song whatever right and I'm
just going you know whatever you know
that that's not what I did but you know
but in what tapes I think you bring the
lens and I have this habit and it's not
a good habit and and it's funny because
I know that people have been annoyed by
my behavior in previous you know jobs
that I've done what's the habit is I
just if it's not my coverage I will say
the lines and I have my lines memorized
and I'll give you everything but I also
tweet and and look at Instagram I play
games it's rolling it's just like but in
this particular time I know that there
was a three-shot on Janna bunch of
people right and I was off to the side I
know that I wasn't on screen but you
know I mean I still had to be there yeah
yes
I just started playing this game called
empires and puzzles right we all know a
shout out yeah breaking I mean playing
it and then it just goes Bobby she's not
wrong I know she's not and I was so
embarrassed then that was like the last
take so I got up and I just walked away
and I went to craft service I just
started pacing like what the [ __ ] why
did you do what are you doing Bobby
you know I like her she's so nice and I
love working with her and she did that
and then and then she got on a bus and
she went away so I couldn't even say got
on a bus you know the van to go back I'm
picturing holding like old school
Greyhound and but then the next day I
walked up to her and I'm so deep and she
was like oh yeah I'd she's like just you
know just don't do that okay yeah well
I'm not gonna hide she's like I love you
and though you know everything was good
yeah but that she needed to do somebody
well it's very important it's like very
very boring to be on a set it's so yeah
so you got to get into questions and
kingdoms and parts of puzzles um another
thing that they do and I'm not
complaining but this is what you're
gonna want to cut out by the way no I'm
not gonna cut no I talk about this all
day okay I love the show and I love
being on it and they know that I do and
everyone loves me and everything's great
and I show up on time and I know my
lines a little okay okay is that the
other day maybe a month ago there was a
scene late night we're shooting at night
and my wife on the shows her name is
Lindsay Price and we're sitting there
for hours going know why we're here
right and she's like yeah but I think we
should they haven't told us that we're
done mm-hmm and then some guy goes some
guy that you think is craft service or
what he goes hey what are you guys doing
at your car because we have a Tesla in
the show that and it's gone from the
driveway which means
yeah why are we even there at this house
so I went up to the director and I go
just three hours and he looks you know
no what are you doing here they didn't
trap you like yeah for like hours he's
like not after what you pulled a Jenner
yesterday no but that was wood before so
they just little things like that you
know I mean this should happen this
should happened all the time on dream
corp to like you know the hollywood
think hurry up and wait
yeah you're you're always on call and
then you basically spend most of your
time sitting down being nervous about
[ __ ] something up yeah right
yeah that's yeah yeah the whole game
that's the whole game yeah well what I
did that you know that movie that I did
with the card whether or not the
Kardashians but the Joe ants John
Haskins that the Australian boys oh yeah
I did a YouTube movie yeah right and I
got there at 4:00 p.m. 9:00 a.m. the
next day I still hadn't charged that
full day a full day went by they didn't
tell you like and not yet at 9:00 a.m. I
kind of I said slept hey Wanda I was lie
down and one draw you know how you would
sleep for a long time you go where am i
day is it and I go to the lady I go I
saw I fell asleep like six hours but I
got here yesterday at 5:00 who's this
lady yeah yeah and she goes oh you're
not we're not shooting you now you know
what told you she moved on to the thing
you know they're gonna get your coverage
you know whatever and I'm like what the
[ __ ] that's what that's YouTube movies
though I didn't catch that one yeah yeah
I'm waiting for my red account to what
don't be mean about it because it's
[ __ ] Hey
Amazon or something if you heard of that
rigging company
[Music]